hey what's happening it's your boy A.D
you know I'm saying that's t-rail don't
worry about nothing make sure you
subscribe man bootleg here we are in the
building right now yes sir oh yeah and
follow figure in the world now and
Community come back on fake and
Community number two podcast let's go
got it Joe Budden we see you
all right man bootleg cab podcast we got
special guests here my guys just started
their new venture
fig Community World fig Community world
yes sir t-rell and A.D are in the
building yes congratulations fellas
it's good to see y'all I'd like to also
start this interview by pointing out
that a lot of people seem to think that
I had replaced y'all or something and
that was nice
I definitively got hit up at lunch uh
the day all that stuff has happened by
Adam and he asked if I wanted to just
because I've been a guest on the show
before he's like hey you want to fill in
for a day and I had said yes prior to
understanding what was going on exactly
what was going on I heard that the Lush
guy got fired and I was like oh well
that's you know and then I called you
and then you were like
I was like
I don't know I don't know that you Call
Lush whacks and I said you call them
corny I said I said I said I don't know
dude but like watching him on camera he
comes off like a cornball and so then he
went on some podcasts a bunch of people
tagged me in and what's up with all
y'all with this white on white crime I
don't I have no problems with that guy
y'all just be everybody I really got
zero problems with that dude like I
don't know him like he's
definitively my Elder he has to be older
people got problems with each other
you're gonna have to take your first
fade in Hip Hop dog
over here I'm like whatever yeah no no
he says I don't think it's any problems
with that dude you know what I mean
anyway congrats guys yes congrats to you
because the spot thank you
very inspiring you guys are killing it
um I mean there's been a lot of uh
you know a lot of narratives about you
guys have popped up on a lot of places
so I think this probably is this the
first time besides your own platforms
you guys have been on camera talking
about this because you guys have been on
like academics thing yeah on camera yeah
this is the first thing I told I told
everybody we weren't gonna uh talk about
nothing until we I was all together but
uh you know since we like you I'm glad
that I'm pundit and come to pack me out
yeah
right now
all week Jesus I mean sometimes you need
that you know what I'm saying so we can
relax and do our thing
um give me like an idea of what fig
Community world is gonna be because
obviously uh the Youtube channel was
started a while ago
here you go
is that where we're gonna no I'm just I
I you know when you go to the page
um good there's a bunch of y'all on
there obviously smack you pun duno
um who like like is it gonna be because
the Wednesday show is obviously
something that the fans are gonna miss
you guys are going to be on your own
version of that we're doing Wednesdays
live I mean so yeah fig Community World
basically is our Network so we'll just
definitely become no jumper we'll ease
into that you know somewhere it's a
bunch of uh podcasts and different shows
different Vlogs like you know different
series and stuff like that so we'll
we'll we'll begin with what we already
have right now which is uh a Wednesday
show and we named it we renamed it shame
on you at the end of the day and uh
we'll take the um we hungry show which
is their food show great show by the way
we starving or something yeah
with somebody who only likes to eat
french fries okay he gotta change his
palette are you saying you have white
trash food uh taste because no no no I
mean my favorite food is french fries so
don't hate on me he goes a nice hotel
give me your French fries you see that
White Band with the headphones on over
there same thing all he does is eat
fries
are they selling macaroni and cheese
more french fries as a side
okay yeah I mean I think I told y'all I
think I told you all like it like last
year I was like you know this I felt
like what was happening that was
inevitable you know I think you cracked
it off I don't know
look at you Stir It Up
no I might I might have I think I told
you I like hey man like you guys know
you guys could be like for real the
drink champs did you say that first so
even on camera he was like oh you and
t-real okay
to the next level I was like
hmm so how how
everybody be like do it do it do it I'm
like how I don't know how like now I'm
just on here I'm trying to figure it out
right yeah that's the thing you just
gotta figure it out then once you figure
it out like okay this is what they were
talking about all right now let's take
the steps toward what we need to do we
thought with our life you know what I'm
saying in the show I mean we it was like
like I was saying it was inevitable
already you know what I'm saying we just
had to make that move a little faster
just due to whatever whatever had to you
know happen to A.D or whatever the case
may be we're like all right well okay
it's just time so let's just you know
what I'm saying pack up and put our big
boy boots on and let's do it anyway you
know what I'm saying and that's just
what happened but what's gonna happen
anyway was it already in motion it was
in motion like months ago I already had
this and that and that's because of the
page so people were saying that they've
been made the page yeah I've been made
that for sure yeah I mean because that
was me
we blaming everybody else
you know that's due to
um
our situation did dinner you know if you
try to cut our water off we got to make
sure we do we supposed to do you know
like the camaraderie of it seemed like
the ship was sinking right and we're
like wait a minute it did feel that way
yeah I think you and I were talking when
the when the battle was happening I'm
like what the [__] going on over there
bro
dissing each other
I mean but it was just one day you know
just one day and you know like I said
that you know I'm not I wasn't put to
ease with that [__] I was uneasy you
know what I'm saying when I could just
wake up one day like yo I'ma cancel all
this and then I look and I'm like you
don't have a backup plan I mean I have
well we was already doing our own shows
or whatever the case may be you know we
was growing speaking of that fig
Community is like number two in all
podcasts
man yeah thank you man congrats I saw
that I was like
take your button slot bruh is that a big
thing even it's a big deal serious
is a big deal because usually you can
pop up there and then like it's three
hours and then yeah you know what I
noticed I'm looking at that and I said
why the [__] is our [__] under
entertainment news
hmm
instead of music so we got to switch
that up man hey stay in entertainment
news man
yeah get in there
come on run that genre right here get in
there I might switch my no no no no
number two yeah
Joe Budden Heaven smack I like that
y'all ain't uh like you guys are
Entertainment Network kind of you guys
do do music you know what I'm saying but
it ain't strictly a music you know it's
time to step up this time to step up to
something new outside of the YouTube
channel the reason why I feel like this
was already kind of in the works because
I know you ad and I know you are not the
most sensitive guy to get that pissed
off about someone saying that you had
the same four jokes I said oh this was
the perfect Catalyst to be like we out
cause there's no way my guy A.D who I
could bust balls with all the [__]
time gets that offended by hearing that
someone thought he had the same four
jokes that he's like I quit y'all we out
it was it was more than just the the
four jokes
behind the scenes but if I think the
narrative is like that was like the the
thing that you were like I'm out it was
the confiding in somebody
that I feel like
yeah you could talk among colleagues and
stuff like that because he could have
told Tyrell that it's when it's brought
to my attention and you talk to me tell
me how you honestly feel because if to
me if you talk behind my back you're
talking about my back about all types so
I don't know what it really is at the
end of the day and it was like also this
was it the same week that the Richard
Spencer thing and I was saying the
timing of everything was just weird it
was like I call you out for this now
this week is and that's one thing people
are understanding well like you guys are
not friends it's business but I'm like
if you leading the conversation is hey
for our friendship to remain I think you
should come do this over here so I'm
like I'm looking at it on some friends
he's wearing it as friend like I'm
putting my my whole life into this this
company for sure you know what I'm
saying so I'm like I just feel like it
should have been handled a lot
differently because I could take hey you
don't want me over here all right cool
I'll come do this over here we can
continue the business going but you know
after hearing everything that transpired
and even after we even made our exit I'm
like oh yeah we made the right decision
yeah it felt like a very you know a
stressful place to be around that's
he was like yo you wouldn't you wouldn't
be on no jumper I was like [__] no I
want no part of that toxic ass but it
wasn't stressful for us when we came in
no no because you guys were like the
crowd favorite you know and you guys
kind of kicked off I feel like you guys
literally kicked off the current
business model over there yeah 100 like
without you there's no him and without
you there's no like random shows that
Adam isn't necessarily on camera we we
just bought like you know a sense of
team and camaraderie to the building
that wasn't there at first because
before that it was just strictly due to
pod ain't no business and stuff like
that and I was like all for teamwork and
when T rail came he's like a real
overthinker he's like look we got to be
a team so everything was just
reinforcing that's how we was moving you
know he'll come into office and he'll
crack jokes with everybody like that's
what make the [__] fun we're sitting
there saying [__] to each other and it
was just all love and [__] too so you
know I also think Tyrell you're like a
natural bro I think I told you
the interview you did with J Stone I
think you did one with mozzie I was just
like those are like some of the like the
best interviews with mozzie and J stone
I'd ever seen and this is something
you're new like you're not like
necessarily interviewing folks like you
know what I mean but I just thought well
Jason I did by myself mozzie we did and
and the collective we did on the Pod but
still that job was like a big moment
yeah yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah two like some of those moments too
like are key for me you know like
especially when you interviewing
somebody and they like barely talking
they saying one word or you say
something they don't like and they look
at you it's just like how you get out
that [__] conversation like that but
I study [__] like you you know
what I'm saying like Adam I I study I
study y'all man because you guys are
like super like great at this [__] like
I'm studying [__] writing [__] down I'm
trying to re-memorize and you
[__] just hop on the mic like
hey what's going on and just you know
super conversationalist but yeah man I
mean that [__] taught me a lot over
there I [__] with it man I'm saying I
appreciate everything that I got from it
you know I'm saying I appreciate Adam
everything he you know saying he gave me
you know I'm saying everything he taught
me
um from here on out but you know we got
to move on we had to do what we had to
do I mean the same four joke [__] was
just like whatever it was just like
icing on the cake from just built up
[__] you know yeah I saw what do you
know it said which I totally you know
yeah like he's just that type of [__]
and I had we all had to hold do no down
do you know I was like bro I'm gonna do
no been wanting to get up he was like
I'm only here for y'all I'm doing
mornings on power 106. yes but you know
what like but it's just I'm like you
know don't do it right now we all got to
stick together hold it down for me you
know what I'm saying hey we I really had
to hold you know down and then this was
just like as soon as that [__] happened
to A.D it wasn't it wasn't me I couldn't
tell doing them like hey like hold it
down some more like it's out like [__]
this is out I'm cool on this [__] like
so we just had to make that move and you
know it's all good like you know what
I'm saying I don't know but he a cool
[__] you know what I'm saying you know
some of the decisions he make as far as
business or whatever the case may be
might not be on point you feel me like
you know and it's just you know it's
it's a learning curve for every [__]
body yeah I think it's a learning curve
for him too because I feel like he's
kind of always done [__] where it's like
just him and recording and editing and
like to like bring in all these
personalities and like you know he's
never really signed people
so I think that like there's that
narrative where he was like well in
hindsight maybe I should have signed him
and it's like and that I I don't know if
y'all saw me on the show oh I was
watching and I was like well if you
enter enter you know encourage them to
to go and do their own thing
like wouldn't that be like with the idea
that they might do very well and that's
and that was where I was that's another
reason why I'm looking at it a little
differently too because it's like if you
pushing us to do these things
and we reach in certain Heights to me it
made you look good right like I'm a boss
that put on these other bosses and put
them in position not like oh we on
competition for each other and I feel
that's when the comments and uh these
outside narratives keep coming out
instead of really looking at who the
people are right you know what I'm
saying because we can get into it I can
get into him but I can talk to him I
don't have to be like hey bro [__] or
tell somebody something bad about him
and keep doing that and me and Adam we
didn't bumped his a million times right
but every time I'm saying hey bro you my
brother I'm looking at like a brother
right you're my brother if you wrong I'm
gonna tell you you wrong if I'm wrong
tell me I'm wrong it's a revolving door
it's not one-sided and a lot of times
like I know for me personally I know it
just felt one-sided it's like yeah you
could tell us when we wrong but when
you're wrong it's like up I ain't got to
say no it's not I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm like bro it
don't work like that I mean I think you
know communication in common sense it
didn't play a big part in this [__] I'm
saying like communication should have
been on an all-time high you know what
I'm saying it didn't common sense just
get up in there especially if you're on
the business level and you think and put
a little sprinkle a little friendship in
there let me get in there man these
dudes is doing their thing I see him
getting hot let me go offer him some
before somebody else uh uh offering
something and let me see what that looks
like you know what I'm saying let me let
me go entertain this let me see what
this looks like and we'll be good we
didn't necessarily have to be on your
platform but it just in a perfect world
if I was to do it and I rewind it I'll
go back you know what I'm saying let me
sign these guys for a year whatever keep
doing you you know I'm saying I'll take
my percentage whatever you're doing you
know I'm saying tours merch whatever the
case may be I was open to whatever you
know I'm saying I was open to whatever
anybody any deal anybody had you know
what I'm saying as soon as I began or
you know saying just leading into it
after a couple months but it's all good
man you know I'm saying it's just
business experiences that people
probably have never you experienced yeah
I think that's really what it is right
it's like that's it dog it's like the
first time you go through something like
that it's like well in hindsight but at
the same time you got to kind of have
the business Acumen to be like well [__]
it's pretty obvious this is gonna this
is getting huge my Common Sense level
come on like maybe I should call a
meeting with the boys and yeah but like
when he said I don't know Joe [__] and
he was like they were enthusiastic
like yeah
yeah like you could have still came like
okay you guys are doing good my bad
let's try to sing right let's try to see
instead of hey guys I didn't realize
this was gonna happen you know we would
have did it yes
all of this stuff is still new right
like we're looking at this and like I
mean you just celebrated a year yeah
you're not at a year yet are you nah I'm
at barely six months crazy
yeah it's wild cool you guys have been
killing so for the new channel obviously
your guys's
um streams on each other's on your own
respective channels are really big
um it's gonna be is it gonna be
streaming [__] or is it gonna
essentially be everything just like you
guys are getting the space we're gonna
have streaming stuff over there we're
gonna have original content any ideas
that come to mind we're gonna be signing
Talent we're gonna be doing everything
we're supposed to do yeah but we also
gonna be taking our [__] time too
we're not going to be sitting out here
rushing just throwing [__] on camera
and just doing anything you know what
I'm saying like we'll take our time with
what we got right now then we'll just
add gradually and then you'll just see
the growth and the evolution and
everything like and it's no need for us
to go in here and rush but we definitely
gonna come with it you know what I'm
saying because we you know we learn from
the best and just looking around you
feel me and having that free spirit and
free mind to go out and try to try new
[__] and you know and have it work like
we've seen the ins and out of all of
that [__] and that's just that was a
great experience in itself though so we
we got the sauce you know what I'm
saying and we're just gonna implement it
I definitely think y'all had the sauce
in that building y'all kind of brought
the flavor over there you know what I'm
saying like Michelle brought the
substance I feel like you can correct me
if I'm wrong but it felt like a lot of
artists had stopped like wanting to go
over there but it kind of felt like
because you were there they would still
go over there is that is that safe to
say yeah I fought hard like I'm telling
people like bro come [__] me man
listen I don't want to come over man
that's for me yeah it's a good look for
me and then you get certain individuals
that's coming through them doors and
upon using his resources he's been
trying to get Q over there for almost
two years he's like ah you know what I'm
saying so you ain't doing no interviews
right now [__] no that motherfucker's
playing golf
he's Rich come where [__] no hell I'm
at the Calabasas Country Club yeah no
but like you know I go to the club and
artists be like bro they watching it
right they just like oh I don't want to
be involved with their platform and then
you know certain people like Wiz come
through hard I'm gonna do this for you
right you know what I mean and pump hey
Mozzy come on there's certain
individuals like okay we made it to
where it was it was cool and I feel like
it got this identity back as far as for
a sec and then the identity became all
the drama man yeah how do you guys
prevent that same [__] from happening
with your well [__] there's a lot of
drama I say we're not doing a good job
because you [__] happened I mean
but you know
initially when drama happens it's not on
us you know I'm saying that it's not our
job to post clips and post the videos
and go hard with it like we're not in
control of that so if drama happens and
then you putting it out that has nothing
to do with us you know I'm saying it can
stay internally it can stay in-house but
if you choose to put it out as a
platform as a company that's on you you
know what I'm saying we didn't ask
nobody to do that we don't control the
clip channel the main channel the
Instagram we're not for sure any of that
[__] so who's really controlling the
narrative you know what I'm saying like
who's controlling what's going on and
what you guys see as far as the drama
and that really was like no on camera
drama like our pod at the end of the day
has never beefed or argued not one
[__] time you know I'm saying in the
other part that left uh which was
disconnected they've never had any drama
at all either so all that other [__] was
just [__] that didn't have anything to
do with us and we'll just speak on it
you know what I'm saying so those clips
will arrive from that [__] you know what
I'm saying and videos are right from
that [__] but still like we wasn't in
control of putting that out so we y'all
written and the people really can't
blame us for that [__] so no you know
what I'm saying and two is you you can't
win for lose because if you don't speak
about it oh you're scared you ain't
speaking about it or you're a PC and
when you do speak about it oh you're a
messy you shouldn't do that so it's like
people don't know what they want listen
do you want to win some money gotta stop
the interview but listen there's so many
opportunities to gamble to bet on your
favorite sports to make Sports more
interesting NFL season is over but it's
all good because the opportunities to
win are just getting started yeah look
there's so many things you can do we're
talking about NCAA NBA NHL UFC boxing
there's Blackjack tournaments so much
money to get in on and check this out
y'all if you sign up right now using the
promo code bootleg do it right now you
can get a welcome bonus up to a thousand
dollars plus you're gonna get a free
hundred and fifty thousand dollar March
Madness bracket contest entry that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
that could give you 200 you put in a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just NBA season playoffs are on
the way man you could like literally put
together some crazy props like uh I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP do you think jokic is going
to win it you think Joel embiid's Gonna
Win It Whatever It Is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas well I think like I
said that too when I was with Adam I
said like wouldn't you rather
have your your boys get the the views
that come with reacting to some of this
[__] because otherwise
a bunch of other YouTube channels are
going to talk about it whether it's
academics or milk 7-4 or whoever the
[__] like people are gonna make their
reactions and you guys have your own
platforms and you guys are kind of the
source it's like wouldn't
I would rather but what makes it any
different don't no jumper do it yeah for
sure yeah but within their school when
they do it's a problem you know what I'm
saying like what do we're learning we're
literally watching what you guys are
doing you feel me you've given us the
blueprint we're designing what we're
doing and adding our own spin to it
around that right so it's like look you
can't say well you guys are doing this
and reacting to this but y'all doing the
same [__] too it may be a rapper you
feel me who don't appreciate that it may
be somebody else but we're literally
doing the same exact thing the people
and like I say all the time we don't sit
there and just wake up in the morning oh
we about to just be messy and do this no
the fans literally will sit there and
spam [__] in the chat like talk about
this talk about this and be like all
right y'all want to talk about this
we're here now right and then it's like
it just blows over and then you know it
is a prime example you know he said uh
you know drama doesn't equal money and
you know sometimes it doesn't but also
I'm in this Kelpie situation I'm gonna
keep bringing it up like we that was
in-house nobody didn't have to know
about that nobody didn't have to know
about the fight nobody had to see that
clip nobody didn't have to do none of
that [__] right you guys chose to put
that out you know why because that [__]
equals dollars you feel me it equals
attention equals because they were like
sitting on that for a while right
sitting on that you know what I'm saying
but you got legal reasons too but you
but if if there were no legal reasons
that should have been put out
immediately you know I'm saying so that
again that's not on us we didn't do that
right we're not in control of that you
know what I'm saying so
now it's becoming Financial this doesn't
equal dollars and there sure wasn't kind
of like well this is the world that you
kind of consciously created yeah like
well you know what I'm saying you
curated this [__] I didn't I we don't I
didn't come there to do that I came here
to laugh but when you put people in
certain situations it's kind of like you
know Love and Hip Hop or something like
that if you know probably people got
problems with each other and you're
curating to put them in the same room of
course something's going to blow up so
even when Kelpie came over there Kelpie
had his situation with Almighty and
sharp it didn't leave on a good note no
it was it was already drama the first
time yeah yes you get invited back to
sit next to the same guy right well
drama don't equal money what you think
gonna happen though yeah but drama don't
equal money so why are we inviting this
young man back yeah why did he come it
didn't make no sense that didn't even
make any sense you know but it does it
did make sense because it makes dollars
and sense you know what I'm saying we
come back because he's viral so let's go
viral again young man you know what I
mean now now we're gonna go super viral
because we can't even bring out the
whole interview so we just gonna put out
the fight [__] it
so I mean hey I mean but [__] you know
it's Financial Times over there I mean
we had to get out of there anyway you
feel me because I don't like I said I
didn't want to be a burden to anybody
because he wasn't making money on our
show our show was you know wasn't making
money and that's what people was like I
don't like that narrative too the show's
not making money we all in YouTube we
all know what's going on yeah per se yes
the long form content may not make that
much money but once you chop it down a
million times put on the clips service
it to to Facebook service it to
Instagram real services to tick tock and
you do all this stuff like that yeah
then it's gonna really be something but
the fact that it's not making any money
that ain't true at all but even if it if
even if it you know it wasn't and it was
just breaking even you know what I'm
saying we're we're still bringing a ton
of subscribers so we're bringing we're
bringing yeah we're bringing people to
the channel so if you you're here
they're living on the channel so if you
watch it at the end of the day and
you're at work and it's only an hour or
two you got six more hours to go guess
what you got to do you're gonna live on
the channel and still watch other views
so it's you can't really determine on
how much money that we were making the
channel in its entirety I know people
who like uh like two or three of my
close friends they're like entertainment
Source was y'all guys are [__] like
yeah they don't watch Netflix they don't
watch Hulu they'll just be like [__]
although jumper you know it's very
entertaining no it's crazy it's like I
mean I I told Adam man I was like dude
it feels like how like Howard Stern was
back in the day because Howard Stern
used to have like [__] 10 different
wild ass characters that were part of
this morning he had things that you
couldn't do in 2023 right a lot yeah he
had chicks riding all yeah but
nonetheless it was uh it was crazy for
sure
um so for for you guys like
um
what is it you is it you guys are
business partners is pun a part of it is
he just managing it because if you look
at that that channel it's pun's face
right in the middle oh yeah but I
changed that [__] now hey defense
static even how that happened so
originally we didn't know if duno was
going you know what I'm saying stick
around right so at the time it was just
gonna be like we started pushing fig
community and when it originally had the
pictures it had um I think it was
t-rail
um pun it was smack and meat it was four
so when Dino said [__] it I'm with the
guys we just added him to the side so
just so it makes everybody it made it it
made it look like yeah pun was in the
middle of the situation but yeah
Community world you know just back on
fig you know I'm saying community and
then the world is doing old world that's
why we added the world because Facebook
you know Ace boys you know I'm saying
Ace boys worldwide so we added the world
because everybody's going to be on there
collectively you know I'm saying they're
gonna have a show on there but yeah the
main people will be me A.D smack Dino
and punk because we curate a lot of [__]
as far as you know the content yo you
guys uh I barely like checked out this
Reddit thing recently because of uh
since I went on the the the show the day
after you guys well not the day after
you quit like was it the day you quit or
whatever
no I'm just saying like I would forget
the day actually no the day after the
Lush got fired is when I went on the no
jumpers after yeah I don't think anyone
knew you were officially quitting no
except Me Maybe
um because he she real danced around a
little bit because well being a dear
friends you know before all this [__] so
I was like hey he's like man we quit bro
I said well [__] I ain't gonna say that
he did like myself how do you feel me
going on Tuesday I'm like go do it
Tuesday yeah go get yourself me I'm like
nah [__] all of that tell that [__] no
but [__] it go ahead now but like just
the um I guess like the the it is a
weird fan base that is very dived into
your personal life it feels like it's
just a lot bro I just couldn't imagine
like it's a it's a smaller percentage of
the fan base it's like a loud minority
yes but they dictate a lot of [__] right
they dictate you got to give them that
they'll put them narratives out there in
certain hoes even myself before you'd be
like damn
we come from where we're not used to
[__] like this right the reddit's in the
four Chans and all these deep diving we
like what the hell they got a 4chan for
y'all bro they got everything
unfortunately I have no idea what the
[__] I'm not talking about steel like I
I've dibbled and dabbles
you're smart be smart I just have too
much [__] to do to just be sitting there
like looking at that [__] because you
know but I feel like if you can read the
worst [__] people say about you you can
take anything
anything but you subconsciously are
affected by that you just you might not
know it until you reel it back okay will
you reel it back yeah and you realize oh
[__] I'm not thinking of it because I I
think um Joe Rogan always says that he's
like I never read the comments ever
because I'm doing what I do without like
like based on my own thoughts and my own
intentions if I start reading comments
it'll subconsciously kick in to like
make me change [__] or be you know and I
think that dog that Reddit [__] is wild
bro see I look at it like this they was
going in on me I don't even know yeah
it's the wrong timing though [__] I mean
you white slash Hispanic I mean I don't
know it's probably not Hispanic I look
at it one slash wait when I'm going when
I'm going out and I'm seeing people
showing love everywhere I go yeah you
feel me that's what you say I see you
hey bro I love what you doing I love
what you doing I don't go outside and
see negative comments bro and the people
around me if everybody's affected and
they feel like oh you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing that's what
I ultimately care about you feel me if
his kids is taken care of and they happy
his wife is Happy bro everybody around
us is Happy it doesn't matter what
nobody else say because regardless if
you like it or not you're still watching
it you know what I'm saying so it is
what it is so you can read something and
it's like all right cool that's your
opinion but when we come outside in real
life when you touch some grass we're not
seeing that yeah because we're running
any of these uh these guys in real life
any of these ready
so why does it affect you and a lot of
you know there's a theory out there
people got a lot of burners and they put
their own narratives out there and stuff
like that so you know yeah when I
learned about the Reddit the first thing
I'm like damn it's a lot of negativity
in there but then as time went on I'm
like okay so you run the Reddit and you
run the race I wasn't gonna say it and
you run the Reddit and you [__] work
here
like what so now I don't believe nothing
who runs it but you know first when I
was you know I'm saying Adam was a
moderator in there Josh was a moderator
in there uh they said you're using
moderator name but I talked to him last
night he said I actually wasn't a
moderator I didn't do anything I had no
control over anything but hey I don't
know how this [__] is ran but uh even if
you're a moderator then you're moderate
moderators I mean hey I mean God damn I
mean and it was a lot of crazy [__]
being sent in this group chat and I'm
like what the [__] who's saying that why
they saying that like it was crazy but
if you sit in there and you like a now
you gotta now you got a whole nother
profile doing this [__] and making up
these narratives is it gets really deep
like I don't think I have that much time
on my hands and this will actually do
know this was the turning point when it
came down to it I'm just gonna say
we'll start talking about topics that
were supposedly coming from the Reddit
and I remember when we was in New York
they lost it Adam everybody lost control
of it and when they lost control of it
oh it was a whole different Reddit so
you know they started asking questions
and that's like wait a minute why are
our women in these red is why are our
kids in these reddish wires why is
everything attacking us but it's not
attacking y'all and it was like oh
because you know the rules are hey
they're not on the table they're not on
the table but we on the table like they
be talking about your families and [__]
everything yeah but it would never it
and we're bringing that to topics that
we're talking about online so it's like
all right cool but once it lost control
then it was like don't talk about it no
more what do you mean don't talk about
it no more we've been talking about our
lives for the last couple of weeks and
now since y'all can't control the
narrative no more y'all don't want us to
talk about it no more so that's when you
gotta you know put your thinking cap on
and say what the [__] is really going on
t-rell obviously you and your girl have
a successful vlog
uh she's got a dope uh woman's uh yeah
shout out to Sorella
boutique.com yeah I mean so I I once
said Tupac was overrated in an interview
and like my wife got like 30 DMS from
Angry uh [__] yeah saying that
you white I'm a piece of [__] and
you
how crazy is like Heather's DMS in terms
of like just these wild like fans Fringe
fans I mean I think they pretty cool I
mean they haven't like went over pretty
respectful yeah they're pretty
respectful right now they they they love
it man that's why you got to laugh at
everything you know what I'm saying We
Gotta Laugh at ourselves and you you got
to put yourself out there because I'm
not a [__] that you can really like
bother and [__] like that like I'm a
[__] that can joke too like like if I
wasn't already like subconsciously I
don't think I'll probably be bothered
anyway you know what I'm saying I'm a
[__] that probably got over all of the
[__] you know I'm saying I have one arm
like I'm going through life with my arm
not working like and I'll let [__]
crack jokes on me [__] with me like all
the whole little [__] so none of that
[__] ever [__] bothers me if they
hitting there up and messing with her
like she don't even look at that [__]
anyway when she do she she got other
[__] you know I'm saying that she's
doing too man have you guys tried to
think of who would be the quintessential
like first guest
I already already got them really I
ain't gonna tell you though
I feel I feel like
a Schoolboy Q or a tiger or they're in
that room okay damn hey shout out to
tiger man tell him to come through yeah
you do too you hey is it Rocky you I
mean I don't have I don't have a
relationship with him he can text him me
yeah I can't text time can you DM him I
could text like why can't you DM them
you can DM them I did before no we know
we know damn
the first for the first interview oh bro
oh we're having the first one
T-Roy you gotta put this out we're
calling you out men this relationship
yeah yeah that'd be amazing my goodness
man what the [__] are you gonna go in
there and talk about you gonna cry like
a little hoe
I miss you
it's been too long
now
oh that'd be great if you guys
resurrected Last Kings in 2023 you're
the greatest you're the greatest
businessman of all time hell no what
would you need that when you got 80
running around here with Cher [__] [__]
last king
yeah he got Avril Lavigne ain't worried
about that [__] it's over I think you
got share out here boy is you crazy we
on this uh Swiss clothing and
sorella.com
um so are you guys going to Adam's
wedding
why is this the biggest like question
everybody said I'm not going to that
[__] [__]
wouldn't it be awkward
goddamn tickets [__] with this [__]
man I'm going look he got me doing all
type of [__] over here bro huh
I did a reverse super Uno uh Nazi nah
still go to Italy have a good time I
love Italy it's in Italy yeah
let's go to
we can do some shopping hey how
hilarious would it be if you guys went
to Italy during the same time
don't let this [__] pump you up
everyone's at the same hotel and you're
like hey we're just we could drive past
the venue
[Laughter]
everybody get scared I mean but if we
did go would it be a problem I feel like
y'all should go I don't but but like we
just joking now like I don't know I got
my ticket
Adam my mind might change May by may 19.
this is all jokes at the end of the day
but I still look at them like a homeboy
right you feel me like if he he can text
me he just text me the other day he
could text me I could text him and [__]
like that like it ain't no bad blood
like [__] appreciate him you know for
we wouldn't even be doing what we doing
right now if he didn't put the battery
in our back so
um we always gonna have respect for him
when they come down today and thank you
go to the wedding
yeah
there'd be no reason why you weren't
invited Heather wants to go if Heather
says if Heather says we're going then we
can still go who wouldn't want to go
it's an excuse to go to Italy
I know it'd be really weird if you guys
went anyway and everyone was at the same
hotel and you're like oh yeah we already
bought our tickets but you know we're
going uh we're going to I doesn't want
to talk business when we get there yeah
no business talk we just go just have
some fun you're like we got to get the
boys back together man I feel like it'd
be natural for you guys to also have
Adam as one of your first guests
wow I didn't think about that why not
bro clear up all the [__] you know
because I feel like you guys genuinely
probably I mean you guys like you just
said you have love for Adam yeah the
feelings Mutual I do [__] that we giving
the beef going
like I do think like like Tyrell like
you were saying I think it's like a big
learning curve with all this [__] yeah
because like I feel like no jumper had
like evolved into something it had never
been before so I'm sure like you know
there's a learning curve on how to deal
with all these personality I mean the
[__] got fired on camera bro you
know what I'm saying like that
you know what I'm saying as a business
owner right now here doing content like
would you would have you know ever did
any of that there's so much stuff that
has happened over there me and Eric my
producer we talk about it all the time
yeah like it ain't worth it it's just
not it's not would you like you know
would you ever as a boss go and fire
Eric like look Eric this camera you the
camera rolling Eric your ass fire get
your ass up well I mean I kind of fired
him before but not like that I was like
hey man you want to be a famous
photographer I need somebody who wants
to be a famous podcast producer
are you throwing shots on my boys
[Applause]
see this is how we do it I see what
you're doing
you're gonna be a stirring up [__] with
our media for me
what you trying to do to me
to be [__] oh my God I'm honorary
Armenian I don't know if you know me too
yeah of course I've been to three
Armenia weddings and a Mexican
oh my wife's Mexican okay shout out
aren't you no I'm not mad we've already
gone through this you know this is
Hispanic I have two Mexican children
damn she be whooping your ass in there
huh
[__] your ass up she be on the
Christian [__] in there
man no
no no
call yourself
she definitely I don't know Christian
[__] oh my God and it's funny because
that [__] is real because they came here
like two weeks ago well that's just real
real and she carved her [__] their
initials into the table right there oh
that's crazy she was like this like
pissed and like I'm like what
[__] it's it's survive property
damage but like an hour prior to them
getting here like well they were here an
hour prior to the interview starting
they were just yelling at each other
while he was getting his hair cut in the
other building I'm sorry Kev that's
probably something that's probably the
best vagina on this planet to continue
to deal with that I don't even bro I'm
gonna be honest
let me give you some head [__] people
like oh my God I forget everything I'm
gonna be I think I think that wipe it
away I think being being near them for a
couple of hours it made me kind of
realize like well now that she's sober
it feels a little like I don't know man
it feels a little manipulative on the
blue face side I feel like he's kind of
running up the numbers right now because
he kind of knows like let's go viral no
no I said it in the interview I'm like
yo she's more popping than you he's like
yeah she signed to me I want her to be
more popular
whoa oh so he's running it up I think
that's more of what's happening so it's
not real no it is real but I mean she's
pregnant God I mean it's a sad situation
I think that whole thing like it's like
kind of what is it worth it the numbers
the money but yeah some of them know
jumper [__] that happened like I
definitely would not name something
talk about it
um I mean the firing thing you know I
think
um I just think that like I was telling
Adam the same [__] like lie to me Lush
no sometimes
um just some of the like I feel like uh
we would talk about like it felt like
sometimes he would just be having random
gang members on that don't really ain't
doing [__] but are gang members I don't
know yeah there was like a little like
point in time it was an error there was
like an era like the [__] Mack era where
it felt like every other guy on the show
was fascinated with Street culture and
it was like uh so and so on being a
something something [__] and going to
jail and being white
yeah like no substance there
I mean but what the [__] are you
supposed to do when no artist gonna come
through there you know what I'm saying
it works right like yes like like to me
like I can't even well like to me the no
jumper thing is working it's way bigger
than what I'm doing but you know for for
for me like just a lot of the like uh
the [__] that happened with house phone
you know I think was was uh terrible it
was mishandled flagrantly even even if
it wasn't meant to be misshandle flake
really like
like I was telling him I was like bro
that that wouldn't even that wasn't even
the sniff the YouTube that wouldn't even
got
you can't even load that up and that's
and that's where accountability goes
into play right well I was just saying
and then even hearing the do no thing
you know like what he said about like
asking for something to get taken down
I've taken stuff down
because I'm like cool with an artist and
they're like hey man I'm getting some
[__] can you take that [__] down and
I'm like yeah sure bro like if I if
anything I'm doing like is gonna affect
your day negatively and it ain't even
going crazy like that on YouTube I
[__] and this was like life and death
situation except little Pub I kept his
[__] up [__] him anyway
oh my God
he gave out my [__] phone number on
on the internet
what did you do bro I asked him if if he
thought J Cole predicted his career
correctly
and then it came out and then him and
his team were blowing me the [__] up
are we trying to stop from coming out
I'm like bro
first of all the interview you you
actually like came off like not like a
little [__] in the interview and
like yeah no it's coming out bro like it
is what it is so then they didn't like
the way I titled the interview so then I
changed the title so I changed the title
to like something nicer right and it
wasn't even titled badly
and then
his manager calls me and is like
he said I better take it down I said I
better take it down or what you know
where I'm at the [__]
I'll be there all day tomorrow what do
you mean you're [__] Square from
Miami some more white dude calls me and
then I got off the phone with him and
then he got people white people I told
you he posted my phone number why all
y'all got beef with each other like that
why you got no beef with no white people
Lil pump see no pump's not white is he
he's like a Puerto Rican Colombian
something and I actually like a little
pump you know oh he's Cuban I didn't
know that no I thought about the manager
pull up whitey
oh my God Whitey
what yeah but yeah then my phone was
going crazy for like [__] a month
straight
I put it on airplane mode then like
right when it happened but dude my
WhatsApp like people when I [__]
pasty fat white [__] sending me net
nudes and [__] thinking it was a little
pump it was it was wild bro it was like
Hey that bad what's up guys hey shout
out to our family at uh blue chew man
listen I know we always are getting
feedback about our Bluetooth interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's their
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discrete package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just drop the
mint chewable same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so what you need to
do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the odd Sox Basics baby yeah so look so
this was stuff about odd stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff oddsocksofficial.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you will save 20 off at checkout try the
Odd Socks Basics if you're one of those
guys who wears other plain white branded
socks plain black socks I promise you go
with the odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they're just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro Stand Down be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview how do
you feel about the racist comment that
was made on uh
no jumper I haven't which was there yeah
it was something about us being slaves I
didn't see that okay you have to check
that one out it was with Destiny and a
few a couple other guys in this young
lady that was on there and they made
some comment that was super crazy
and uh the guy Dijon he kind of posted
it to on his uh Instagram yeah report
card yeah the poor card guy yeah so was
it an anime the joke or was it the other
guy or uh they both made the joke I mean
something about uh you didn't you
thought I was black I'm a black slave
something along those lines but go look
at it it's kind of ruffling
he said oh you know I thought you was
something that you were in hip-hop
you were in hip-hop and it was like oh
no I thought you was just a slave owner
that's what Adam said
it was yeah okay do you guys think you
guys are I mean I don't think Adam's
racist do you guys think he's racist no
me personally right
yeah I don't no I don't think he's
racist I think that sometimes like when
I see something to defend him because I
see some of these old tweets going viral
I think white humor is like super dark
at times and mind you there's some [__]
that like was joked about that I
wouldn't joke about but I know people
but then again you still have a guy come
on like Richard Spencer and then it kind
of makes you question yourself like [__]
like why would you bring that guy over
here on this platform when you you know
you have everybody around like I don't
see him as a [__] reform
so I mean I think back to like when he
they did Nick Fuentes you were part of
that conversation I think it would have
made sense to have a person of color be
a problem yeah a part of that
conversation I mean I watched some of it
and it seemed like a pretty like good
combo
um because I was like yeah why would
that because I just think of that dude
as a tiki torch guy you know from
Charlottesville so then I started I
watched like maybe like 20 minutes of it
when I was cleaning my office and I was
like oh this dude is like uh is he he
like turned in his racist car or some
[__] I don't know but yeah I don't know
man I think I think that kind of [__] I
think you know I think Adam obviously
wants to do more provocative content now
that is like more like on the political
fringes bro he's older bro and like you
know even like a year prior to that he
was like listen to this podcast and it
was literally like three hours about the
covet vaccine right some [__] I would
never [__] listen to in my life so I
already knew like his mind was pivoting
somewhere else like his interest is not
hip-hop anymore and he says that that's
and that's my thing is it's like it's
kind of tough probably being hit because
I don't I don't necessarily I've never
looked at Adam as like a quote-unquote
hip-hop head I think he's a guy who like
like is a fan of rap music who kind of
like fell into being a part of the
culture you know what I mean I think
he's just a very logical guy I mean yeah
for sure it's like he can pick up
anything and just have a logical answer
for it and he's a very good
conversationalist he's a great podcaster
and oh he's a businessman he'll see
something that's working he'll say let's
amplify this once it's not working no
more we moving on to this and he's had
some of the best hip-hop interviews ever
you know so
kudos to him but if you're like tired of
chasing down like what's hot on
Soundcloud or I get it amazing
interviewer for sure he's great man yeah
right here though yeah it's an interview
he right there I'm coming for uh coming
I'm coming for bootleg calf
hey man come on man you ain't white he
ain't gonna beef with you yeah I'm
coming for bootleg I'm rooting for y'all
man give me some of them damn artists
but they come here and tell them to come
over here to me let's share it when are
you guys launching the uh like the
actual like original shows I know you
guys said you're not rushing anything I
mean we were supposed to launch it uh
tomorrow right but I'm sitting here with
you you know I'm saying I have some
technical difficulties to hooking up
cameras and wires and [__] but I I
rather I came here for you thank you
yeah I made sure I made sure to call if
it don't come out today I mean tomorrow
I mean hopefully this week if not next
Wednesday yeah
why was that like black people on time
bro I had a rough morning yeah that's
crazy super rough morning my dates out
let me see let me see
I gotta get the [__] out of here too I
love you today super rough morning
um
the 29th if we don't do it by tomorrow
the 22nd it'll be aw it'll be the 29th
it'll be the 29th yeah yeah this coming
out tomorrow okay yeah so perfect this
is your Wednesday show for the week guys
yeah it's our Wednesday show y'all
saying shout out to everybody I'm saying
shame on you I'm saying I got my boy 80
here we missing two other [__]
but yeah um last thing what happened
with sharp last night man man that [__]
was uh
he was I can say for me
I was he was being loyal
to no jumper because he's still over
there and I was just trying to break
down like
there's a ceiling for us there was like
you two were having a civil conversation
is friends that was respectful
the people around me now pun tray
um hold there's a lot of other people
that you don't see on camera they're
tired of like having to hold back on
account of me you know I mean because
it's a lot of like you know Shady things
that have happened in business and stuff
like that where you know I try to look
the other way and they're like nah you
know it's time like we can't do this we
can't do that and
if you feel like your boy is being done
wrong and you're explaining to somebody
why that is wrong see one thing that
sharp said in that when we was having
that conversation he said you had
Leverage
I'm not looking at something that
somebody I consider friend is leveraged
with our relationship or business at the
end of the day I'm looking at it like
[__] if you my brother if I feel
betrayed I don't give a [__] how much
money I'm I'm losing out on I don't care
about how much the situation may affect
my livelihood I move off of morals and
principles right so if somebody is
blankly going on platforms and saying
like hey you don't like me and T rails
progress because you think that it now
is too uncontrollable and it's too big
now to where you can't put us on
contract why have leverage like that
that means that you're always going to
keep us a step below no no I think you
have the power to do that obviously
now that you get all now you get that
full context yeah talking about it more
but I do think that like
I think sharp was just kind of
presenting an angle of
had you guys came in and be like hey
we're about to [__] leave double our
pay or you know what I'm saying like but
again I just think that but it's not
about the money bro no no I get that I
get that so I just I but I think that
like you know when you're talking to
people about [__] like they're just he's
just sharing one perspective I just
think I was like I was like oh you guys
were get like it was a civil
conversation but even even and then our
guy pun yeah but even though it comes in
like a wrecking ball OT wasn't feeling
the conversation either yeah because
people like like me I got my grandma's
heart I listen to everybody I hear
everybody out and I try to see the good
and everything and the people around me
they watch me get burned six million
[__] times right and they're tired of
that [__] so that's where that
aggression comes from it's not
necessarily oh sharp you the bad guy
because a lot of people were like oh
well maybe you you feel like you made a
bad decision no I stand on every
decision that I do and the people around
me they've been waiting to just be
Unleashed because they've been seeing
behind the scenes stuff that they didn't
like and I still look at it like you
know what
uh maybe this maybe this maybe that nah
bro this is what it really is it's cut
and dry it's in your face and if you
can't process that
and see where you're wronged in a
situation then hey can't expect nobody
else if you were us if you were us what
would you have done oh I would have did
what I told you all to do exactly but I
think that my my whole thing was is the
one thing I saw last night
um that
worried me was it it was like
I don't want y'all to go down that path
of like just [__] like like it felt like
okay obviously you and and sharp are
having a civil conversation which is not
necessarily the greatest thing for views
but what is the good thing for views is
putting the punstigator on to go crazy
on Sharp and like my thing is as Sharps
like your genuine homie like you guys
hit him to talk about what was going on
you know what I'm saying he decided to
hop on give you his perspective whether
or not you agree with his perspective it
was responsible but just being respected
that was like that was real it was raw
right it was it was curious and honestly
like did you think you putting punt on
three-way with sharp was gonna go well
um I didn't even think about it you were
just like hey he's calling like I'm like
honestly that was like we just hit the
100K Mark we was having fun everybody's
just having a good time right I thought
I thought me personally it was gonna go
a different type of way right see I
think sharp took it personal when he
said well I'm still at no jumper is it
[__] me when it was like NADA we got a
problem with anybody we gonna say [__]
you right you don't own no jumper you
feel me if my homies is on hey ad got
done wrong we not [__] with them that
don't mean his [__] Almighty that don't
mean as [__] sharp that don't mean as
[__] Flaco we still talk to everybody
that's on there Flocka was just you know
what I'm saying us still have a
conversation with people that don't know
jumper did you call him after the uh I
talked to him after the stream and I
told him I was just like listen bro like
the way that the people feel about
certain situations like we're not dumb
we know what time it is like if it's a
great business decision for you I don't
expect you to leave right that get your
money if you getting paid what you
getting paid over there get that bread
yeah you know what I'm saying OG suicide
that's my uncle you feel me I told him
stay over there right if they're taking
care of you and they doing it that's
something in your best interest go ahead
and do that I'm not going to get in
between you and money and I don't expect
everybody to make a decision that I made
Tyrell moved off the just pure loyalty
he said he didn't want to do it without
me I said the same thing if Tyrell was
out we wasn't going to do it we do know
what's talking about leaving if do not
would have left before that we had a
chance to leave we would have left a
long time ago because we like [__] the
camaraderie and what we have we can't do
this with other people bro right and we
can do something but it's still not
going to be the same in that magic and
we got to stick together well I think
the timing worked out man so next
Wednesday will be the first yes new show
new food show coming the whole universe
is coming proud of y'all man shame on
you I can't wait to see uh what y'all
got coming bruh yeah shame on you shame
on you next Wednesday the 29th 29th man
there it is appreciate y'all fellas
appreciate it appreciate it boom